I spent years and thousands failing at
trading trying to become consistently
profitable. But what changed that for me
was focusing on one really simple
strategy and has now helped other
traders transform their trading as well.
In this video, I'm going to show you the
simple steps to look for the strategy
every single day, but also a ton of
trade examples of it so you can also
pick up on the nuances and little tips
and tricks that come through years of
experience in executing the strategy.
Don't just watch the first trade example
and the quick walkthrough. You need to
watch all of these examples to really
hammer the strategy in. I'm sure if you
have been struggling trading for a
while, you can relate to a strategy can
look simple on a video and in hindsight,
but when it comes to the reality of
actually executing it every single day
on a moving live trading chart, it's
really hard. So, let's jump into a quick
overview of this strategy and then into
some live examples showing you the exact
strategy. I took a small account where
you can start with risking less than $50
a trade to now where I'm risking over
$1,500 per trade. It took me over seven
years to find this strategy that finally
made me consistently profitable. Let me
teach it to you in under 4 minutes.
Every morning at 9:30 Eastern Standard
Time, I open my charts and look for key
price action from the overnight and the
pre-market data, marking off key areas
of support or resistance where I think
the market is likely [music] to reverse
off of. Then I go into a one minute
chart of the same market and I look for
30 minutes after the market opens. The
S&P 500 for me opens up at 7:30. So I
mark 7:45 and 8 o'lock. These are key
times in the market where I have
consistently noticed that it will cause
a reversal in the market. And so I like
to be hyper aware of when these times
show up. Once the market opens at 7:30,
I watch to see the price movement of
those first 15 minutes. Does the market
make a flush up or a flush down into one
of my support zones and as well as one
of those reversal timings. [music] And
if it looks like it's hitting one of
these potential timings and reversing
and bottoming and has potential to go
up, I will look for a few key factors to
enter into a trade. The four key factors
I want to see for entering into a
reversal is one, this move down into the
zone and my reversal timing is it needs
to be a strong flush [music] down. If
the market's all choppy and not moving
easily, it's unlikely to reverse easily.
Good trades happen in volatile markets.
Number two is the current trend that
it's in needs to be broken. Because I'm
looking for reversal trades, I'm often
betting against the current trend. But
to do this effectively, you want to
enter in when it's clear that that
current downtrend has started to break.
And so to do that, I either look at a
trend line based off of the current
trend, if and when that has been broken,
or I watch the swings of the current
trend. What are the lows and the highs
doing? Once the market stops making
lower lows and lower highs and starts
making a higher low and potentially a
higher high, well, that is another key
that the trend is shifting. And then
finally going into a recording of this,
the last thing I'm looking for to
complete this head and shoulders is have
this big bullish candlestick break the
highs here. And then when that happens,
I enter in an order betting that the
market's going to go higher and I put my
stop below the previous swing low
because I'm going with the swings of the
market. And then so for a target, I'm
looking to see the downtrend get
reversed all the way because when the
market moves down in such a rapid
fashion, it's an unhealthy trend [music]
and it's likely to reverse higher. And
so ideally, at a minimum, I'm going for
two times my risk or even better is
three [music] times my risk. And so I
slowly manage and target those rough
areas. And as it gets up with this
specific trade, I pretty much close out
at two and a half my profit for a little
over $4,500.
So, I'm jumping along here. We've had a
really nice flush lower in the opening
15 minutes. And big picture, we've had a
big sell-off overnight. And so, I think
uh we might have a essentially a fake
lower here and then a rip higher
potential. Um, so I didn't I this was a
little too aggressive to get it on this
candlestick
because it could just pop up here um you
know recover this a little bit and then
continue lower. But seeing it pull back
here um essentially make a higher low
and then I got in on the break of this
swing high here. So that essentially
confirms it's making a higher low and
starting to make higher highs as well.
you know, pretty much the opening price
is here and so I don't think I'll go
break even until it kind of comes up
here to 2x. Big picture, it'd be sick.
You know, just looking at a fivem minute
a and even to pull down at 15 minute big
picture here is, you know, we've been in
a strong uptrend and we had FOMC
yesterday, lots of volatility,
good potential to rip back up today. Um,
I don't know if I'll be able to hold
through that whole move, which is
totally fine. Um, I would rather just
capture the initial easy spike this
morning, but I do want to
try and be be patient with this because
sometimes these flushes in the morning,
it could pop up here, pull back, and
then rip higher. Um, and because today
has
such a high volatility chance,
I want to give it some wiggle room. Um,
you know, it's it's it's really easy and
nice to try and go break even early,
take that risk off the table so you're
not scared and nervous about losing that
money um or or giving up your profits.
But it's a lot better usually to just go
with what the market is telling you. And
I could totally see it come down here,
retest this low, which is yesterday's
huge swing low off of um
FOMC. And so as it rockets up here
though, um what I want to be looking at
is I'm not going to get out on a 3x
here. I think maybe a four if it just
spikes like that. Um,
but I do want to see
how this initial pullback plays out. Um,
it's scary kind of risking
giving back essentially all this profit
and the loss here, but in reality it's
really unlikely it just spikes like
that. Um, this is a really good signal.
NASDAQ is recovering as well. ES is
stronger this morning and that's why I
went in on the ES. Um, you could see
based on just this pullback right here,
these two candlesticks. If we compare
that to these two candlesticks on
NASDAQ, a lot weaker. And so I took the
NASDAQ over that. Um, and so as this
goes kind of parabolic here, um,
I like to get out if it breaks that
because it there is it's hard because
there is big potential today and a big
picture to continue higher, but there's
also
these
I just want to mark these as minor
reversal zones which can cause
a move that's this aggressive to turn
around.
Um, so
that's kind of what I'm seeing here
today. I think at this point because
I've hit 2x, I'm going to go break even.
If it pulls all the way back here, I'm
going to get out. I don't want to risk a
loss at that point.
That's a nice little one candlestick
pullback. Um, this is a huge
candlestick.
And I don't want to get greedy here
because this is kind of crazy movement.
Um,
I just want to see what for where Forex
is
at a spot where we are. I'm going to
start I I'm pretty much having a mental
stop at this point because this is just
going crazy and obviously I've been p
super patient the whole week.
Um,
[sighs]
and this is, you know, my heart rate is
spiking and I'm nervous and excited. Um,
I, you know, I basically have to hold
back here, hold a pullback here. I'm
going to close these out here. Just
knowing that it's hitting this is
important. Um,
I want to give it [clears throat]
a little more room here. I'm just trying
to look at where a 50% pullback is.
Okay, we've already done that. Never
mind. Um,
in terms of management, I mean,
obviously I'm I'm going to get out if it
comes all the way down here. I would
like to get out somewhere up here.
Obviously, if it's going to stop, but I
also want to see it pull back here and
push higher a bit more. In these
uptrends, they can have little pullbacks
like this. Um, and so
I want to give it room. It's not really
at a big level to where I would expect a
reversal.
But once it spikes up one more time, I'm
going to get out. I'm happy with that
profit. I don't need to be going for
$10,000
um with how fast this is moving because
this could just rip lower on a dime
here. I think if it chop starts to chop
here one or two more candles, I'll pull
my stop up here.
But I would really love it if we broke
higher and I hit 6K on a trade. That
would be my biggest trade so far at this
size. And obviously that would be a
shitload of money.
But you know, you can't think about the
money too much. You need to focus on
what the market's telling you and
following your strategy. And my strategy
is try and hold with this uptrend until
it tells me otherwise. And it's starting
to slow down here.
But it also looks like it could make one
more break higher.
Trying to be patient here. Not let the
nerves um
get get me out here
because this is a huge strong candle and
it's really just flagging out here.
[sighs]
Just going to be patient.
Wait for one more spike higher and then
I'll tighten up.
because it really looks like it's going
to. And if it spikes here and rips
lower, then I'll get out as well. That's
a good signal.
I'm going to tighten up below this
candlestick.
And I think it's either going to rip,
continue to rip after that chop right
there, or it's going to slow down.
And I'm just going to leave my my limit
where it is.
I'm totally happy getting out if it if
it does that and rips lower.
I of course obviously it was so close to
getting my limit there which sucks, but
getting out right here is still a sick
win. It's still 3x really
just way. Yeah, we're out.
What we're looking at here is actually a
one minute chart of the NASDAQ futures.
Now, again, you can trade this on
either. A lot of the times these markets
mirror each other. The reason why I
trade one over the other is I like to go
with which one has better volatility
because volatility is good for trading,
especially reversals. And so in this
case, you can see at 7:30 my time, which
is the US market open, market opens
here, and just immediately, pretty
quickly reverses or continues to move
lower. It does it pretty aggressively in
a fast-paced way. And so for me, what I
see that is, okay, that first keys me
into, hey, we got good movement. And
when there's good movement like this, it
makes it likely to actually reverse. And
so when it comes to 745 right here, I'm
looking at, okay, does it look like it's
going to reverse yet? Is there a reason
for me to think that? Are we at a key
level? It's not there yet, actually,
because at 7:45, the price was right
here. It's not at a support zone yet.
Another key thing is I like to look at,
okay, what's the current trend? And in
this case, it was sticking to this
downtrend. It hadn't shown that it was
had clearly broken that yet. And so in
that case, I stayed away and let the
market continue lower. And so as the
market started to make a double bottom
here, it eventually broke this
downtrend. And really the second step in
my major checklist that I use to get
into every trade. It's really important
to have a consistent plan that you
follow every time when you're trading
because it allows you to consistently
repeat it over time. If you're just
blindly following or reacting to what's
the market's doing and, you know, go
with what you kind of think is going to
happen, you're likely to have
inconsistent trading results over time.
I found that I became profitable when I
started consistently just looking at
these timings every morning, but also
sticking to kind of the same style every
morning and just looking and waiting for
the market to have one of these patterns
show up. I don't take a trade
necessarily every morning, but when I do
take trades, they're highly consistent.
And so the last couple things here is
when the market made this big move down
here, this big red candlestick, and then
had two strong green candlesticks here,
that showed me that this was almost
essentially a final push lower that is
now starting to fail because of how
reversals work a lot of the time is
they'll have a good consistent
downtrend, but when that downtrend
actually breaks, two things can happen.
It can either just reverse right away or
it'll make an attempt to keep going
lower here which will fail and it will
reverse and it will start a uptrend. And
so that's when I essentially jumped in
on a trade right here. I'm actually just
going to quickly zoom back in this
recording just to show you really walk
you through the nuts and bolts of
entering in on these trades in this
futures market. And so how I do it is
every time I look to enter in on a
trade, I want to wait for that last
confirmation. And so that last
confirmation is for me in this trade was
seeing these two candlesticks and then I
wanted to see how the market reacted to
that cuz sometimes I've seen it where
it's come up and touched essentially the
previous high of where this big bearish
candlestick was and then just continued
lower. And so for me, I'm seeing, okay,
well, it's had this bare candlestick,
which is, you know, it's come up and
then that bare candlestick is showing
it's trying to go lower again. And then
this green candlestick that's forming
right now that just finished, it's
showing that it's breaking above that
previous high. And so I just enter in
essentially above the break of this
high. And so that for me is a a good
momentum play versus getting in on a
limit order. And so that's what's really
important about trading futures and
trading in general is your entry and how
you specifically enter. I've always
found it to be more beneficial to not
try and enter in on a limit order, let's
say down here, or trying to enter in on
a small pullback because those are
really hard to gauge. And also a lot of
the times is if you try and enter in on
this little pullback right here, well,
it could just be you're entering in on,
you know, when it continues the
downtrend. I find when I enter in on a
stop market order or a break above a
previous high is you're entering in when
that pullback has already happened and
the momentum is in your direction. And
because a lot of these reversals, and I
like to enter in when there's a lot of
volatility, when the momentum switches
like this, even if maybe your entry
price is a little worse in terms of
entering in up here versus entering in
down here, if the move's going to go all
the way up here, it's still a great move
to capture. The whole idea with trading
is you're capturing most of the move.
You don't need to be capturing all of
the move. Like for instance, this chart
right here we were looking at earlier is
entering in here, I would enter in on a
break above this candlestick. And every
time I do, I actually use a tool that
I've created for Ninja Trader that
really helps with futures markets
because it allows you to say, "Hey, I
want to risk let's say $725
in a trade or roughly around $700." And
it allows me to say, okay, I want if I
want to risk roughly $700 every trade
and my entry is here and my stop loss is
here, how many contracts do I need to
trade? And that's a hard part about when
you start trading futures is figuring
out how much to risk, especially if you
move this around and the risk changes,
but allows you to target roughly the
same amount every time and it doesn't
grossly over exaggerate how much you're
trading. And then of course you can see
your targets here. And I like to go for
roughly generally two times or three
times my risk. That's a good sweet spot
for trading is when you enter in is
going for that because you don't have to
be right every time and allows you to
take only the best trades and capture
good profitable wins from them. And so
to show you how this trade played out is
I jumped in, put my stop loss below this
big candlestick here because I felt that
hey I think if it comes down here again
it's likely to just continue lower and I
want to get out and the downtrend is you
know even though it's broken this
downtrend here that doesn't mean the
downtrend's over. It could just be
shifting you know to a not as strong or
directional of a downtrend. It's more of
a healthier downtrend with pullbacks.
And so at that point though, I roughly
up here is about that two times profit
[music]
limit order. And so you can see here I'm
trading six contracts because that's
what that tool essentially told me to do
based on risking about I think it was
actually I was only risking about $500
on this trade. little smaller size than
my normal, but because the market was
pretty crazy this day, and so I was
risking a smaller amount. But because
there's a high volatility, even though
I'm risking a smaller amount, if the
market moves in my favor pretty far, I
can still get a really nice big
profitable win. And so as this shoots up
here, what I'm looking at is okay, is
there a uptrend here that it's, you
know, as it if it breaks that, I might
want to consider getting out because
same thing with, you know, taking the
reversals over here. If this uptrend
breaks, I think it's likely to reverse.
And so my initial target here is, you
can see I have a resistance zone drawn
up here. patter. So, that's what I like
to use for targets as well, working
through these trades is pingponging
between essentially major resistance and
support zones. I drew kind of an
interesting box here. And what I'm
looking for with this box is I'm
thinking, hey, I think the markets had a
nice breakout up here, but I think it
could, even if it breaks this uptrend
that I have drawn, I think it could pull
back somewhere into this support zone
because this is where there were some
previous highs. You got to give the
market wiggle room when it starts to
work out in your favor because otherwise
it's very easy for you to manage it too
quickly and get out too early. That's a
really hard part about trading as well
is jumping into these trades and having
this risk and dollar amount on the
screen and holding off and not doing
anything. You want to have a plan going
into managing your trades too of okay,
when am I going to move my stop loss to
break even? When am I going to get out
of the trade? I roughly change it
between each trade based on what I'm
seeing. But I have, let's say, a rough
flowchart of like if it does this, I'll
do this or if it does that, I'll do
this. And you can see here at this point
I've moved to break even because we're
pretty close to three times my risk
here. I think maybe two times, but it's
moved up to where I'm starting to think,
okay, it's likely it's going to start to
slow down. And so at that point, I break
this up because my thought is, and I
don't recommend doing this right away,
is I want to take off half of my trade
if it's [music] breaks this tight
uptrend here. And so it closes out
pretty much half of this trade right
here at an aggressive stop-loss. I think
it closes about $700. And then at this
point, I'm also thinking, hey, it could
start to slow down here. There is kind
of an uptrend, but this is a nice
pullback with a retest, strong bullish
candlestick. And so, I think if it's
going to keep going higher, it's going
to keep going higher. And if it comes
and breaks this new swing low it made,
I'm happy to get out and I'll close out
at about $1,500.
Okay, coming into today, I've taken a
few days off from trading. And so, it
helps me to get back into the swing of
things by visualizing what I want to do,
reminding myself how my strategy works
and what I'm looking for. You know, what
is that repeatable thing that I'm
looking for every day versus just kind
of showing up and being like, okay, I'm
just going to trade. Um, and so for me,
um, one of those big things is
going into, um,
some of my recordings of just past
trades that have done well that are
basically just are wins that hit my
criteria and seeing that, you know, it's
like, hey, I want to just see the market
come up to a spot
um, and
hit kind of make a double top, hit my
timing window, and then take a trade
based off of that. And so for me, that
helps me, you know, kind of trigger.
Okay, I'm not looking to just do random
things or react to the market. I want to
wait for a specific thing, you know, a
nice spike 8:00 or 30 minutes after the
market open to show up and then, you
know, take a a reversal. And that's kind
of my bread and butter. And essentially,
that's what my repeatable setup is. And
so going into today, looking for
something like that. If we look at the
ES futures, just to bring up my drawing
tool here, um, on a 15-minute chart, you
know, we had a crazy selloff um, Friday.
And this was just Trump announced some
kind of tariff news on China. I think he
tweeted it or something, but the market
just went crazy over it. like looking at
a daily chart
um you know it was a it was a huge spike
down um and so
you know we came to actually these
previous highs which I think is a great
spot for a bottom um and if if he
doesn't really follow through you know
the thought is is it just going to be
you know a smaller version of April
where we just rip lower and then once
people were like oh he's kind of backed
off on that um we might just shoot back
up because the market overall is
insanely strong right now and so I think
it's totally possible that today looking
at this we probably want to retest this
to some extent and we have done that um
you know we started to recover pull back
this really kind of tested this the gap
we had there's still technically it
closed here and opened here so there's a
pretty big gap there but we have come
down to to really fill this gap this is
the major gap here. Haven't quite filled
it. So, I could see us selling off a bit
more to do that. Same thing with the
NASDAQ. Pretty much exactly the same
setup. Um is we've had this downtrend or
trailing off. Um started to fill this
gap, at least tested the middle of it.
And so, going into a smaller chart, what
that looks like for a trade today. Well,
you know, 8:00 is here. Sometimes you
can get a reversal 15 minutes after the
open, but today I think if we can get a
good bottom, I think it's totally
reasonable. Actually going back to a
15-minute chart here is if we
target these overnight highs. Um, you
know, the market kind of just giving
back this move up, finding some
strength.
Uh, but just got to pick the right time
to buy at the bottom for that. And so,
uh, market hasn't opened yet. got 7:30
my time is when it opens. And then other
couple windows I like 7:45 and 8. These
are my two spots where I want to see it
come down in reverse if it's, you know,
either way at those timings. Um, that's
kind of lines up with what is repeatable
for me versus I find, you know, going
into the market and
just trying to enter in randomly just
does not work very well. um or or
reacting and just reading and thinking I
can read the market in real time um if
it doesn't fit one of those kind of
things. So um another thing would
potentially be well if it comes down um
bounces and then sits here for a minute
and looks like it's going to go long
maybe like a fake lower and then goes
long that could be another potential
trade of a fake out lower um to again
try and fill my bias to the long side.
So other than that, it's kind of just
waiting for the market to open and and
seeing how
uh it reacts.
It's still a little early for a
reversal. I really like the potential
here though um in terms of like, hey,
just testing this area again before we
go higher. Um, I want to see I would
prefer to see a double bottom. Literally
just something like this. A little bit
more of a stab lower here.
Uh, and it's also technically 41. This
red line is 45. And that's this the
15-minute timing
way more often lands up on that really
clear window than the 8:00. The NASDAQ
has broken the low versus the ES is
holding, but they're close enough that
I think if it's, you know, if it's going
to bounce, it's going to bounce either
way. Um, I think I would prefer the ES
just because it's looking more bullish.
NASDAQ sizing is just kind of funky
right now and get more of a better
target on my sizing
with the ES.
I think if this this candlestick closes
up bullish up here, I am going to go
long with
how the market has been um recently in
terms of
just reversing quickly at these times.
Um and that's definitely a clean double
bottom at that point this point if if
this bar just rips higher.
So, what I would like for a long here
now that it's broken the lows,
um, I would want a head and shoulders to
go long here because otherwise if it's
way more likely that we just, especially
for the NASDAQ here, is come up here,
test this, and just continue lower
because we're not really bouncing off of
a a support level. Now, we we could just
be doing a failed breakout of the
overnight lows here, but big picture, we
could just be in a downtrend
um that's going to continue lower, you
know, and so
I don't want to jump in long here
saying, "Hey, that's a nice failed break
lower um when this downtrend is so
strong.
I like this to the upside.
I really want to see. I'm nervous that
I'm just going to it's just going to
pump me in and then rip lower, but I
think I'm just going to get in long
um through that nervousness because
it it's made a nice head and shoulders
there. I'm going to just put my stop
down here.
adjust this slightly.
Um, and then target the highs.
It's a nice setup. Maybe I should have
my stop down here. It's just hard when
it's such a a rip. NASDAQ has kind of
done the same head and shoulders. I
think it looks really solid.
In terms of a setup, we had a nice flush
lower, nice little fail breakout lower.
In terms of target, I mean, initial is
going to be here.
Um, the previous open
or or the open of today, which is
basically here.
Uh, if we rip up and hit 2x pretty fast,
I might jump out.
Um, but I mean ideally we try and go for
the highs, but also one thing to keep in
mind
is pulling up a channel here
is we could totally be in this kind of
channel right here.
It's not super defined.
You know, it's kind of off of these
three, but that's pretty solid in terms
of resistance. So, so there's this
downtrend line here from that channel.
Now, if you're new to futures or haven't
landed on a trading platform you like, I
use Ninja Trader. I've used it for over
5 years. You can check it out via this
QR code or the link in the description
below. I want to see how this reacts. I
don't want to do a trailing stop just
yet because, you know, if it if it does
like a two candlestick pullback here,
just like this, and then continues
higher, I want to I want to hold through
that. I don't want to get ripped out by
that.
It's scary at this size and I'm still
getting used to that
and it' be really frustrating if it
does.
But pulling back, you know, looking at
the NASDAQ here, trying to be unbiased
that I'm in a trade, pulling back to
here and going higher is totally
reasonable.
Just kind of waiting to see what happens
at this point. Okay, nice rip higher
here.
Again, looking at this. Um, I'm just
going to take this out to clean up my
chart a bit. Being aware that there's
this downtrend here. We could still
totally just reverse after that pop up
and it could be like a final fake li
higher.
Same thing on the NASDAQ.
I think if we break break my stop here,
it's basically breaking this uptrend
anyway.
I'm happy with how I'm managing it. I
just emotionally I really would love a a
win that's higher than
$1,700 if I get stopped out. I'll be a
little bummed about that. But again,
At the end of the day, I
the entry was really good, which is what
I've been struggling with. Management,
you know, that just plays out how it
plays out. It's just emotions talking
really
big picture. Again, this is such a good
for, you know, this whole swing. It's a
nice fake lower
and reversal higher. This is what I've
been looking for for weeks really with a
lot of these openings is reverse
or fake the way I don't want and then
take a trade the direction that my bias
is or I think the big picture is.
I'm just going to move this down to 3x
at this point.
I I I think that's emotional. I want to
see what how this plays out.
I definitely if this starts popping up
here, I'm gonna move trailing stop
like really tight here now
like up to 2x.
NASDAQ is popping as well.
For me, mentally, I feel like getting 5K
on the trade is kind of a mental number
I really want right now.
Um, it's not good, but that's just the
reality.
But I also don't want to just let that
control what I'm doing. I want to run a
trailing stop here. If this is just
going to continue to pop,
I don't think that's over greed. I think
that's,
you know,
I'm just going to put a trailing stop
here right at the bottom of this candle
because I think either it's going to
keep going up or it's going to knock me
out. And if it knocks me out here at
4700, I'm totally happy with that.
Come on. Hold. Hold and keep going.
That's okay. I'm totally happy with
that.
Could
I have got out at 2x? I could have got
out at 2x
or 3x or or could it be um smarter to
just to hold through that pullback?
Totally could be,
but
it was kind of hitting that mental
number that and and my 3x target that I
just want to get out at. Um, but six
start to the day, six start to the week.
That is exactly what I want to be doing
in the mornings. And that's my
repeatable setup right there. You know,
get the emotions of managing it and
dealing with this. You know, maybe if
the if I wasn't as triggered by the
money right now, I would have held
through this and let it do a 50%
pullback and let it go higher.
But all things considered,
I waited for that setup. This is exactly
what I wanted. Um, and that's what I
want to be doing with my trading, you
know. Um, that's what's repeatable
and that's how I will be consistently
profitable. Perfect setup [snorts] would
be if it bounces here and then fails and
I get in short as it breaks the lows.
That would be a great setup. It doesn't
need to be much of a pullback. Even just
like up to here somewhere, some kind of
spike higher. The ES is still grinding
lower, which is good. I'm really nervous
and or not nervous, but really just in
my head just thinking I'm just going to
miss this. It's just gonna just going to
go without me and it's just going to
grind lower, but again, I want to wait
for my signal. I haven't taken a trade
in a while. So, there's some FOMO there.
That's a tiny bit of a higher a lower
high, but really that's just like a
micro spike. I wouldn't really say
that's enough. I need more than that.
It's nice that it made a new low. So, I
feel like the fake lower flush has
happened. And so, we're now seeing if
that fails. I really don't want to get
short on that, but it's like I I don't
really need that much more of a
pullback. So, it's like do I just do it
and then have my stop kind of just up
here? I think I just want to wait one or
two more candles, see what it looks
like, cuz it looks like we might start a
bounce here. Nothing to really note on a
fivem minute candlestick wise. It just
looks like we're kind of chopping at the
top. ES kind of looks the same. Okay,
that's enough of a spike higher. I would
go short if it made a new low. The ES
basically same thing. We basically have
a head and shoulders forming. It's
definitely making a head and shoulders
here. So, I'm going to get short on this
if it breaks lower. Just waiting with my
order below this low. It'd be nice to
not get in on a huge spike lower, but
that's definitely a pullback that I
like. It's kind of a funky head and
shoulders, but it's good. Showing good
weakness. And then we have nice target
down here. 3x to the open. Good signal.
It's all that matters. I was patient and
waited. If it pulls back on me, so be
it. Stops in a good spot. So, all you
can kind of do is get in when you get
the signals and then let the trade play
out. I'm happy with how patient I was
there for really the proper signal. I
would say big picture for targets. I
mean, I think going for the open is
great. I'm just trying to give back this
move. That would be the ideal thing. I
don't if it gets going, you know, we
could get further down. Um, you know,
yesterday kind of that's exactly what
happened. We had a spike up, sat there
for a while, and then sold off to the
open. Uh, and then clearly continued
lower. I don't I I think that's unlikely
that I hold through that, but always the
possibility is always there. And of
course, we could come down and and tap
this as support and continue higher if
we're going to stay in an uptrend. So,
that's one thing to be aware of. I think
it'll just see how the trend develops.
Do we flush down really fast and is it
just worth to just jump out or do we,
you know, kind of go in a methodical
downtrend and I can manage uh my stops
efficiently? I'd probably only go break
even once we kind of came down here. So,
trade is going to do what the trade is
going to do. At this point, that's not a
good spike lower. I mean, that makes me
think I'm just going to get stopped out.
It's going to continue higher. But, I
mean, I'm happy with the trade. I think
I waited for a good signal. If it was
going to go, that's where it was going
to go. That was the good entry. Um, you
know, you can't control what the market
does after that. All I controlled was my
entry, and my entry was good. That's all
that matters. Okay, time to lock in.
Looks like we're starting to get
movement. Um the level we've come down
to is, you know, we're kind of we've
pretty much come down to yesterday's
um chop range on the NASDAQ and the ES
has come down to yesterday's close. Uh
and it looks like we're pretty much at
the 10:00 a.m. reversal time. Nice spike
trend spike again, and then it tried to
keep going lower, and it looks like it's
failing. I want to see it take out this
swing high right here. That confirms to
me that it's starting to make new highs
that are higher. So that kind of
confirms an uptrend for me. So that's
confirmed. Now the last thing I want to
see is a pullback. I want to see it
essentially come down to here, maybe
retest this high, and then um I'll look
to jump in a long off of that. You know,
maybe if it if it pulls down to here.
Um, and then I'll jump in long after
that cuz I want to see essentially a a
really confirmed uptrend. ES is
basically acting the same. It's a little
bit tighter. It hasn't sold off as much,
but there's good alignment there. So, I
think we have a good potential. It's
basically made a double bottom here. Um,
I just want to see a pullback here and
then, um, I'm going to look to get long
on the NASDAQ here with idea that on a,
you know, on a fivem minute, we've got
really nice fair value gaps from this
morning, especially this opening
selloff. That's this um, and I think big
picture, you know, big picture looking
at 15-minute chart for the ES or the
NASDAQ, we're in this, we're in this
uptrend. You know, this is this could
literally just be a pullback. doesn't
look as strong on the NASDAQ, but the ES
for sure um is just kind of in this
uptrend. So, it looks like it could just
be pulling back to here and going
higher. Um and the NASDAQ has, you know,
made a good flush lower, too. But I
think overall is uh on the bullish side
as well. So, let's see what this
pullback right here plays out. I would
like a little bit more of a pullback
than this one candlestick.
um getting long off of that just feels a
little aggressive. Even if it, you know,
it could poke up here one more time and
do a bigger pullback, that's fine
because of this choppiness. Um
I want to be careful here. It'd be
perfect if it pulled back. I think down
to here would be a little better cuz
that's much more of a a real attempt to
go lower versus this is kind of like,
okay, it's a little pullback. It is kind
of hitting this which does look good.
And the ES here is looking to make new
highs. It does look good though. I
personally I kind of would like a little
bit more of a spike lower, but I could
put my stop all the way down here. I
want to see how this new high acts. Does
it just hit that and then flush lower or
does it kind of hold that? It's always
super hard waiting for this pullback
right here cuz it feels like it's just
going to go up and I'm going to miss it.
And I got to just accept if it does
that, that's okay. I want to wait for
this pullback because if this pulls back
and rips up, I think that looks solid.
And also, this is where, okay, this
would just sell off. If it's gonna I'm
avoiding the loss by waiting for this ES
is selling off. It's a good retest kind
of candle. If it reverses that, I think
that's solid. I'm going to put a an
order up here cuz if it does just
reverse that and break that high, I'm
okay getting in before the candlestick
closes. Ideally, it would close here and
then push and after even if a little
pullback because getting in on kind of a
flush higher is kind of scary sometimes
just with how the market can be. Looks
like we're in long. I would like to
target the open, but it's hard to know
what the market's going to do. Got nice
potential on a fivem minute for this to
rip up. Just got to let it play out now.
I think the potential's there. If it
chops around, it chops around. I did
everything um good for entry that is in
my control, you know, waited for the
pullback. Nice signal. Now I just have
to let the market play out. Depending on
what this this move looks like, you
know, I'll manage and either get out at
3x or
um you know, size scale uh trail up my
stop. But I'm not going break even until
it probably comes up here somewhere.
Looks like I chose the right market this
morning. If you look at the ES, it's
that's not even moving yet. would have
entered in here and it would have been
it would have been down. So that's
ideally we need both to get moving
though. The the ES needs to be at least
come up to here. That'll help push up
the NASDAQ more. So just got to let
things play out. I think the the swings
look good for the long side. The ES
looks like it's just kind of struggling
to break through the overnight swing
here. This is the part where you just
got to be patient and do nothing. Just
got to let the the market play out. Even
though sometimes I wish I could just
click a fast forward button because it
kind of just sucks waiting for your fate
to be decided. That's a pretty gross
candlestick. If it doesn't get gobbled
up pretty instantly, that could be a bad
sign. Hopefully get go it gets gobbled
up. We could there could be a uptrend
right here, but that's a pretty big
bearish rip lower. just kind of makes it
seem like we're going to make a new low
or just make one more flush lower before
it reverses. That is crappy. I don't
know if I want to stay longer and see if
this I think the it would have gone up
here if it was going to go up. Even if
it was like this and so it making a new
kind of stab lower here, even if it you
know bounces here and does eventually go
up, it's, you know, my read is
essentially off and it's not acting how
I am seeing it. And so usually I find
it's better to just call it for the day
and not try and take more trades on a
day where the market's not acting how
you would envision it to act just
because it makes it harder and less
likely for a trade to actually work out.
Now the biggest thing that I have
learned from using fair value gaps is to
look for reversals instead of looking
for a continuation. So how I use them is
I essentially see the fair value gap
indicator pop up. And to me what that
says is that this market is overextended
to the downside and it needs to reverse.
and that these overextensions are great
targets for when you jump in a trade and
catch a reversal based on that. That's
the power of using these with a few key
steps that we're going to go over. But
when I was trading this, the biggest
thing that I like to see with these is a
previous clear support resistance level.
So, if we kind of zoom out and look at
the big picture, as the market's kind of
selling off down here, I'm thinking,
okay, what is a clean area that I think
that it's going to bounce down here is a
good level. And I would say over here is
a pretty good level, too, because we had
this big crazy move and this was
basically yesterday's low. And so,
that's why that to me was a worthwhile
level to pay attention to. And so coming
into this, that's what I was looking for
was well, okay, we have this big move
down. So that's the first thing that
kind of keys me into, okay, pay
attention here and these big fair value
gaps indicators are popping off too. And
then if I actually go into a recording
of the trade on a one minute chart, this
is that move down and that support level
that I'm looking at. I'm looking for the
market to break this downtrend line.
It's pretty clearly done that. and then
essentially catch a double bottom here.
And so what happens is the market
essentially double bottoms here. I like
that idea of we're in an area to look
for a bottom. And so just to kind of
zoom this through because I just want to
show you some quick overview and then
we'll get into a few key factors in a
second of really what make this super
powerful. This trade I actually took
small size because it wasn't a really
really good crystal clear setup for
using the fair value gaps. This next
trade I'll really show you the power of
it but just to show you how this one
played out is I had a couple of targets
here is you know mid-range of
essentially this is where those fair
value gaps were. I was targeting
essentially two times my risk as a
profit and then this one was, you know,
if it just shoots up, I'll take some off
there if it gets all the way up there.
Um, eventually what happened is I got
out half at two times and then it kind
of slowly moved up, slowly kind of
started to sit there and slow down. And
so I essentially trailed up and closed
out with closing out for about $1,100
total on this trade. closing out the
first and the second half of that trade.
And so that's the trade I took today. So
this is a decent setup on a 5m minute.
It's got a really nice clear double
bottom. And so that's the couple factors
that are really important when it comes
to this. The biggest thing is yesterday
I went three times that size on this
trade right here because of a few key
factors that weren't in the last trade.
And so just to kind of zoom out to look
at this to kind of show you, well, this
was what I was looking at before. We had
a big move up here. And so kind of just
zooming out, there was a big all-time
high right here. And so pulling that
resistance zone over as this market kind
of popped up into this, I'm thinking,
okay, look at these moves. The market
opens up right here at 7:30 my time. So
the market opens up and instantly
skyrockets higher making massive fair
value gaps pop up and multiple of them.
If you compare this one to this trade
over here that I took today is you know
there were some fair value gaps and it
had a nice move down but there wasn't a
massive red box here of clear
overextension. And if I actually go to a
one minute chart of what this looks like
and and I actually traded this on the ES
instead of the NASDAQ, but you can see
it's pretty similar. There's a bunch of
overextended boxes. I'm not going to get
into why I traded the ES over the
NASDAQ. If you watch the live stream
recording of this, you'll hear why, but
essentially, you can see here the market
just kind of shoots up in about honestly
20 minutes. It makes a massive move up.
I'll pull up the recording of this now.
As you can see, it's coming up right
into that resistance zone that I'm
looking at. And I really sized up on
this trade because of a few key factors.
And now, let me kind of give you a deep
dive into the checklist I use for each
one of these trade entries and how to
know why the fair value gap is going to
really reverse versus, you know, before
a lot of people will try and see that
fair value gap and kind of buy here
looking for it to go long. And sometimes
that'll happen and I'll avoid those
trades because of a few key factors.
Also, if you're wondering what trading
platform I'm using, it's called Ninja
Trader. I've used it for over 5 years.
It's amazing. I'll leave a link in the
description below this video if you want
to check it out. You need just the
basics of this fair value gap to be
popping off. And the biggest thing is
having a bunch of them compared to the
trade today I took. That'll really
increase your confidence because when
the market whips up that high that fast,
it's really likely to give it back up
because of remember that imbalance in
the market. That's what really makes
this so powerful and allows you to when
you trade to enter in and risk a smaller
amount or have a good riskreward ratio
to where you can be risking, you know,
$100, $1,000, doesn't matter what your
size is, but you're going for three
times your risk. That's a massive key
when it comes to trading. For me, I have
found that's way easier to be successful
at. And so, kind of the first thing is
you want those fair value gap
indicators. And then second is coming up
to this resistance zone. You have to
have a key level to be trading these off
of. You do not want to be just trading
them randomly. Here's a clean example of
really just right before this trade
happened is where there's this is big
indicator of overextension, right? But
you can see there is if we kind of zoom
out, there's not really a good clean
level. There's kind of something here,
but if you really zoom out, that's
middle of the range. They're good
extreme levels down here. I I'm not
going to go over how to draw key levels
in this video. I'll link a video up here
on how to do that properly. But that is
why and a reason why you want to stay
from away from something like this
because there isn't a good zone to
reverse off of. You need to be waiting
for there to be a really clean zone like
this and then going into a one minute
chart because I like to trade on a one
minute chart right when the market
opens. I'll take a 5minute entry a
little later sometimes or if the
market's a little slower, but in this
case I took it on a 1 minute because it
made a really nice setup. Now another
huge factor in this trade is there was
timing. I have three kind of timing
windows I look for and the window this
one aligned up was 30 minutes after the
market opens. I constantly see reversals
happen at that time. And so this is a
another catalyst on what makes this a
really good setup. And then kind of the
final thing is, you know, you have this
uptrend that's broken, but a big thing
is looking at the structure of the highs
and the lows, the swings. And so here,
you know, in an uptrend, it's making
higher highs and higher lows. And so I
need to see that stop and it make a
lower high. This is a massive key factor
here. And so from that point, that's
when I look to jump in the trade.
Sometimes I'll look and say, okay, I
like a fivem minute better, but the five
minute kind of just chopped here pretty
good, too. So when I was actually
trading this, this took a long time to
get going. On a 5minute it looks pretty
simple but on a 1 minute it took about
20 30 minutes to get going. And when I
was trading larger than normal size I
put $1,400 of risk on this trade. My
kind of normal large size is a,000. And
because this was such a good setup I did
a little extra because of how confident
I was in it. And so it makes just the
waiting even that much worse. And so
eventually they'll punch down here, move
to break even, and set a limit order
here at two times my risk. Essentially,
a good target is [music] the bottom of
the main move. That's the easy money if
you ask me. And then after that, my
thought was, okay, I will trail this
thing and let it keep going if it's
going to keep going. But if it has a big
pullback like it just did, I'm going to
get out and call it a day.
Huge move out this morning. Double top.
I didn't want to short because the trend
is so bullish,
but I want to see how it essentially
reacts to this level. Is it going to
essentially bottom here, or is it going
to continue lower and we get more
downside? Uh, I think that's more of a
move that I'm more interested in. I
mean, on a one minute chart, these
candlesticks are huge.
So, we broken this downtrend. I don't
know if could be another downtrend right
here.
Trading a little longer than normal, but
I'm kind of making a conscious decision
that
there is a lot of movement right now to
continue trading.
I think the NASDAQ and ES I've I've
you know hindsight it's like oh I wish I
got in here but there's just so much
chop here it just makes it more likely
we come down here and
you know have difficulty continuing
lower. Now that could be totally false
and we just continue lower. Um but I
think I'd rather focus on gold here.
I need more of a pullback though. It
needs to come down to here essentially
like retest this. I want to see it
retest this. And if it doesn't do that,
then I I'll get out or I'll be done for
the day.
Would I go long right here? It's It's a
pullback. It would be nice to get a
little bit more just to get a really
good idea like okay it's faked lower you
know make sure that this is failed
because otherwise this could just be a
continuation lower you know big picture
could be
it bounces here
and it pushes lower,
but I also don't think I can really wait
for more confirmation. It's made a nice
higher low off of this area I've looked
for. It's a double bottom head and
shoulders, I mean, off of this
um
previous high here. Nice bounce there
and then a bounce here. So, that's
pretty dang good structure. My kind of
the only thing is I feel like my
intuition is kind of saying that this is
um it's already had two big moves for
the day
and so
it might just kind of
start to go a little sideways.
um seems unlikely that it's going to
continue up,
but it's also hard to say when gold has
just been so bullish.
You know, these fair value gaps feel
like good targets.
Okay, just going to be patient and and
see what happens. Overall setup is good.
It just may take a while.
Pretty
scary spike there. Not really much I can
do. Just letting things play out, you
know, on a 15-minute. I think it's a
good spot. still
just nervous about
trade not working out just because I'm
on a downswing
and you know maybe a little frustration
over the fact that I
kind of saw this short on the NASDAQ and
ES and didn't take it because I was
thinking that it would be tricky and
unlikely to really play out.
Um, but it didn't really show what I
wanted. You know, I just I don't really
like slow reversals like that. They just
don't work very well. I want to see more
structure like this, like head and
shoulders, clear moves.
Um, I find they're they're just more
likely to work out. And so in hindsight,
seeing it work sucks, but also
um it it wasn't a trade I wanted. So
accepting that and being happy about
that. And I'm just nervous about this
gold trade just because um it is a
little later than I normally take a
trade and it feels like uh it could just
be getting choppy. But also
I'm just nervous because I'm scared
about the outcome. You know, what if it
loses here?
But, you know, again, the reasons to get
in were solid,
and that's that's what I want to be
focusing on, right? It's not about the
trade outcome. It's about the process of
executing when it's
follows your strategy and and pushing
through that nervousness and emotion and
not letting that control you.
Man, this is a serious
chop fest. I'm just trying to wait it
out. watch from my phone. Um, looking at
it, I mean,
big picture, trying to be unbiased, like
it just looks like it's just going to,
you know, it could just chop here, but
it could just, you know, the trend could
just grind it higher. So, I'm not going
to go break even yet until it,
you know, breaks out, I think, of this
this range it's in. My stop's in a good
spot.
Okay, that's a pretty nice breakout. At
this point, I'm going to move to break
even
because I think if it pulls back,
>> [clears throat]
>> um,
you know, I want to get out. Uh,
it could, you know, it could totally
come up here and
slow down. Um, kind of what I'm looking
at is, you know, bouncing off these
highs or this previous low being an
issue. Um, I'd love to get 3x,
but you know, it might just take a while
to get up there. It's got going, which
is really nice,
but it's not at a point where I want to
take anything off yet. It's nice to be
up money for once, having a trade
actually work out. Uh,
but, you know, again, I'm looking for a
larger move here, and [clears throat] I
want to at least target try and target
3x moneywise in terms of trying to like
feel uh good contentwise.
be nice to be hit over 5K. Uh but again,
I'm just going to go with what the
market's showing me. And right now, I
think it's it's at this spot where we
might slow down. We might come down and
and bounce off this previous high uh and
then continue higher. So, just, you
know, going to keep
waiting it out, you know, uh stops in a
good spot.
I I mean I think likely I'll probably
just literally just get out of my limit
order if we get up there because looking
at the highs
uh kind of dragging both those over.
Those are those are here. Um I mean this
is a insanely healthy trend if you think
about it. Uh you know pullback moved up
chopped for a long time and then moved
up. And if it's just going to grind
higher I would love to stay in it. But
also, um, trends like this can just have
a snapback, uh, and giving a lot of that
up would suck. Um, and so
I'm just distracting myself. I'm
literally downstairs, uh, taking apart
my vacuum cleaner and just cleaning it
out, you know, just doing something
meticulous.
And that just allows me to kind of sit
in this trade and kind of let it do what
it needs to do. If it breaks this down
uptrend though, I don't think I'm going
to get out just because of how healthy
it is. I think it it could totally just,
you know, it could have a pullback to to
these highs right here, you know. Um,
again, I think the big picture looks
really good. If it starts to, you know,
get something going in terms of changing
what it's doing, then I'll maybe come
back and and and think about getting
out. But at the moment, um, you know, I
think it looks solid to just keep gr
grinding higher and and I'm happy to be
in
for that.
Okay, this pullback definitely doesn't
look great.
Um, but I need to see kind of what it
does. I mean, it's just so unlikely that
it just, you know, the fear is, oh, it
just rips all the way down here.
Unlikely, you know. Um
it's more likely that we I I want to see
how it hits this bottom because you know
again looking on a fivem minute
it's just a slow chug higher
and so it's hard to not overmanage in
spots like this or or get scared by
flushes like this when it could just
like it's doing right now hopefully just
pop right back up. Um, I think if it
makes a new high here though,
I'll move my stop here. If it
starts to go like this or something,
I'm going to stop here. Something like
that.
Okay, there's another spike lower
hitting this low.
that could be a a break of this trend.
Now, I need to see a couple candlesticks
and see what it does. Um, but I think at
this point I'll move my stop loss up to
here at least.
I would really
be kind of upset to get out here.
It's giving room to see if that spike
gets reversed, but
looks like it's not.
Damn. I mean, that's just part of
trading.
It looks so close to getting like a
really big win. Um,
but you know, getting out here still I
was happy with how I traded. I think I
stayed in it. You know, getting out
somewhere up here would have just been,
I think, kind of, I don't know, more
emotional and just because the trend was
still in play. there was no reason to
get out based on the charts until now.
Um, so still a nice trade. Nice to get a
something in the books, but bummer that,
you know, to get knocked out here, cuz
part of me is like, oh, it looks like it
could just knock out and then reverse.
But, you know, that's that's the signal
I'm going with. And I'm going to call it
a day on that. Now, if you want a
complete free course on this, check out
this YouTube video here. It'll go
through how futures work, how you can
get started trading them, and every tip
and trick and market strategy and
advanced reading of the market that I
have figured out over my years of
trading.